do you think it's crazy no okay you grew
up in the south and maybe for more
humble beginnings then obviously now
like do you think it's crazy of like my
husband I talk about this all the time
with my life like in our life or like
wow we came from like nothing and like
you know do you think about that like
yeah I come from real humble beginning
me too I think when I was six years old
though is when I heard a voice that
changed my life forever and that was
Whitney oh and I heard the song the
greatest love of all such an epic song
the lyrics are so prevalent still today
right I love that's literally I love
hearing now what were your kind of
beginnings
you better have been humble Tony my
favorite thing to do is I go to a mall I
my first mall
no but I remember when I moved to New
York my first show with Shakespeare in
the parking lot in the East Village I'm
not kidding we did Taming of the Shrew
in a parking lot in the East Village and
Iraq it sounds like a garage band oh no
we do Shakespeare next to all the East
Village folk I love is in the mid-90s
yeah to top that Nicole I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this